♪♪
Valerie: THE MYTH WE'RE TESTING IS WHETHER OR NOT
WE COULD USE A FIRE EXTINGUISHER,
LIKE IN THE MOVIE "GRAVITY," WHERE SANDRA BULLOCK'S CHARACTER
USES A FIRE EXTINGUISHER...
IN THREE...
...TO REDIRECTION HERSELF...
...TWO...
...AND PROPEL OURSELF IN SPACE.
...ONE.
WHAH!
[ ROCK PLAYS ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪
I'M COMING, ELIJAH! I'M COMING!
[laughing] STAY THERE.
♪♪
Narrator: CLEARLY, OUR BUDDING SPACE CADET
HAD NEXT TO NO DIRECTIONAL CONTROL.
I JUST OBLITERATED THE FINISH LINE.
-IT WAS BEAUTIFUL. -FROM THE INSIDE,
ALL I SAW WAS JUST LIKE MIST AROUND ME
AND THEN I SEE [laughing] LIKE A POLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Narrator: BUT IT WAS ELIJAH'S FIRST-EVER TIME
FIRING A FIRE EXTINGUISHER.
HIS FAILURE MAY HAVE BEEN OPERATIONAL INEXPERIENCE,
RATHER THAN EXPERIMENTAL.
[ CLATTERING ]
SO, HE'S GETTING ANOTHER CHANCE.
OBSTACLE-COURSE FIRE-EXTINGUISHER TEST,
IN THREE...
...TWO...ONE!
♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S ALMOST WORKING!
Valerie: OOH, NO.
Jesse: GO, HIT IT. AAAAH!
♪♪
[ CHEERING ]
-YEAH! -YOU MADE IT!
[ DELIGHTED LAUGHTER ]
THAT WAS AMAZING!
DUDE!
THAT WAS PERFECT. WE ACTUALLY SAW YOU
STEERING YOURSELF WITH THE FIRE EXTINGUISHER
AND IT LOOKED LIKE IT WORKED.
Elijah: I MANAGED TO NOT KNOCK OVER THE FINISH LINE, THIS TIME.
Adam: THAT'S A HUGE BONUS, 'CAUSE YOU WERE ABOUT TO.
YOU SAW IT AT THE LAST SECOND,
ADJUSTED YOUR DIRECTION, AND MANAGED NOT
TO KNOCK IT OVER, AND YOU WERE ALMOST GOING TO.
[ SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC PLAYS ]
LOOK, FOR THE FIRST PART OF THE TEST,
IT WAS AMBIGUOUS, WHETHER ELIJAH
WAS SHIFTING HIS DIRECTION
OR WHETHER HE WAS JUST PUSHING
THE OBSTACLES OUT OF THE WAY,
BUT, IN THE FINISH LINE, IT WAS TOTALLY UNAMBIGUOUS.
HE WAS HEADING TOWARDS THE RIGHT-HAND GOAL POST,
HE GAVE A BLAST IN THAT DIRECTION,
AND MADE HIMSELF GO CLEANLY THROUGH
WITHOUT HITTING ANYTHING.
♪♪
THAT'S WHAT I CALL A SUCCESSFUL TEST.
Narrator: A SUCCESSFUL TEST REQUIRES A REPEATABLE RESULT.
YOU'VE ACHIEVED SOME BALANCE WITH THE FORCE.
JESSE'S UP NEXT.
HOVERCRAFT OBSTACLE-COURSE TEST IN THREE...
TWO...ONE!
♪♪
WHOA! OOH!
[ ADAM LAUGHS DELIGHTEDLY ]
HE'S HITTING ALL THE OBSTACLES.
♪♪
WHOA! UH-OH, UH-OH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Valerie: AH, JESSE!
♪♪
Jesse: IT WAS A LOT HARDER THAN WHAT IT LOOKS.
YOU HIT EVERYTHING.
YEAH, I KNOW.
YOU CAN PRETTY MUCH SAY THAT I DESTROYED THE SOLAR SYSTEM.
♪♪
Adam: JESSE'S TEST WAS NOT NEARLY AS SUCCESSFUL AS ELIJAH'S.
HE DID HIT, I THINK, EVERY SINGLE PLANET ON HIS WAY.
HOWEVER, IT WAS CLEAR HE WAS CHANGING HIS DIRECTION
WITH THE FIRE EXTINGUISHER.
IT'S JUST THAT IT WAS HAPPENING
AT A MUCH SLOWER RATE THAN IT SEEMS TO HAPPEN IN THE MOVIE.
SO THE FIRE EXTINGUISHER HAS TO OVERCOME A TON OF INERTIA,
WHICH MEANS EVERY REACTION IS MUCH SLOWER
THAN EACH OF THE PEOPLE TESTING EXPECTS IT TO BE.
♪♪
ALRIGHT, VALERIE, IN THREE...
TWO...ONE!
♪♪
UH! [ LAUGHTER ]
SHE MADE IT! SHE MADE IT!
HEY!
♪♪
Narrator: YEP, AND A SIMILAR RESULT FOR VALERIE SEALS THE DEAL.
ALL SIGNS POINT TO THE FIRE EXTINGUISHER
LACKING ENOUGH THRUST TO OVERCOME AND CONTROL
THE MOMENTUM OF OUR ASTRONAUTS
IN THE SAME WAY IT DID IN THE MOVIE.
♪♪
ALRIGHT, GUYS, WE HAVE GATHERED
ALL THE EVIDENCE I THINK WE CAN.
HOW DO YOU WANT TO CALL THIS MYTH?
I WANT TO CALL THIS MYTH BUSTED, AND FOR THREE REASONS.
UNLIKE THE MOVIE, WE COULDN'T REVERSE DIRECTION,
WE WERE BARELY ABLE TO STEER, AND WE COULDN'T GAIN CONTROL
WHEN WE WERE SPINNING OUT OF CONTROL.
ALRIGHT, I THINK YOU'RE TOTALLY RIGHT.
IT'S COMPLETELY BUSTED. BUSTED?
BUSTED. BUSTED?
BUSTED? BUSTED.
BUSTED. OKAY, THREE, TWO, ONE.
All: BUSTED.
♪♪